tried to figure out, you know, for loops, if statements and stuff. And then I was like, wait a second, like with these like couple tools, you could do, you could do anything. And then like the next two to three days, like disappeared. And I wrote this like 3000 line poker simulation. Cause that cribbage scoring is very interesting. Algorithmically. It's, it's one of those things that I periodically go back to
试着去弄明白，你知道，for循环、if语句之类的东西。然后我就想，等一下，就用这几个工具，你几乎可以做任何事情。接下来的两三天，我就像消失了一样。我写了一个大约3000行的扑克模拟程序。因为纸牌游戏（Cribbage）的计分在算法上非常有趣。这是我偶尔会回去重温的事情之一。
as sort of a coding practice coding exercises welcome to adsp the podcast episode 209 recorded on november 12th 2024 my name is connor and today with my co-host Ben, we chat about board games once again. We talk about Scrabble, Cribbage, the games we programmed when getting into programming, and more. Let's put a bow on the board games, and we'll just call this board games. Because you only mentioned one. Other top favorites of yours? Oh, let's see. What have I played? Oh, I really liked Paleo Vet.
作为一种编程练习。欢迎收听ADSP播客第209期，录制于2024年11月12日。我是康纳，今天和我的联合主持人本一起，我们再次聊聊桌游。我们谈论了《拼字游戏》（Scrabble）、《纸牌游戏》（Cribbage）、我们在刚接触编程时编写的游戏等等。让我们给桌游的话题画个句号，我们就把它称为“桌游”吧。因为你只提到了一个。你还有其他最喜欢的吗？哦，让我想想。我玩过什么？哦，我真的很喜欢《古生物兽医》（Paleo Vet）。
Paleo Vet? Paleo Vet was a game I played with some friends lately. Yes, you are a veterinarian and you are taking care of dinosaurs. And every turn, there are five dinosaurs in the middle of the table, available to tranquilize and bring back to your veterinary practice. And once they're in your practice, you are healing them. Each dinosaur has some icons on its card to say what it requires to be healed. Maybe an antiviral, maybe antibiotic, maybe surgery, something like that nature, right?
《古生物兽医》？《古生物兽医》是我最近和朋友们玩的一款游戏。是的，你是一名兽医，正在照顾恐龙。每一轮，桌子中间会有五只恐龙，你可以把它们麻醉并带回你的兽医诊所。一旦它们到了你的诊所，你就要治愈它们。每只恐龙的卡片上都有一些图标，说明它需要什么才能被治愈。可能需要抗病毒药物、抗生素、手术之类的东西，对吧？
There are different things you can do. And you roll dice, and they're not numbered dice, they're dice with icons on them every turn to figure out what you can do that turn. The dice have icons corresponding to the treatment icons. And the goal is, of course, to bring dinosaurs into your practice and heal them and then release them. The wrinkle
你可以做不同的事情。你掷骰子，它们不是数字骰子，而是每一轮都有图标的骰子，用来决定你那一轮能做什么。骰子上的图标对应着治疗图标。当然，目标是把恐龙带进你的诊所，治愈它们，然后释放它们。这个游戏的转折点
is that um dinosaurs aren't very friendly and um you while they're in your practice basically they are they are tranquilized they're asleep while you're healing them but their sleep counter is ticking down every turn um when they wake up they break out and run away if they are carnivores first of all they eat another dinosaur and then they run away so but then so so far this sounds like why all bad right but but then then you start to layer on the things like um extra points for achieving uh sets of dinosaurs. Like you can specialize in healing carnivores and that gives you like extra powers and extra points perhaps, or, you know, things, things of that nature. And, and the dinosaurs, and here I'm aware I'm using dinosaur in a loose term. So I think any large or not necessarily large,
在于，嗯，恐龙不太友好，而且当它们在你的诊所里时，基本上它们是被麻醉的，在你治疗它们时它们在睡觉，但它们的睡眠计数器每一轮都在倒计时。当它们醒来时，它们会挣脱并逃跑。如果是食肉动物，首先它们会吃掉另一只恐龙，然后逃跑。所以，到目前为止，这听起来很糟糕，对吧？但随后你开始叠加一些东西，比如完成恐龙组合可以获得额外分数。你可以专门治疗食肉动物，这会给你带来额外的能力和分数，或者诸如此类的事情。而且，恐龙——这里我意识到我是在宽泛地使用“恐龙”这个词。所以我认为任何6500多万年前爬行动物家族中的东西都算作恐龙。所以，我们可以争论翼龙、鱼龙之类的东西。但这些是
but basically anything in the sort of reptile family from 65 plus million years ago counts as a dinosaur. So, you know, we can argue about pterosaurs and ichthyosaurs and things like that. But these are
经典的恐龙。这真的很有趣。这似乎是另一款好游戏，它很好地融合了策略、运气和选择路径。这是一个有趣的游戏吗？我想我从来没听说过它。是的，我在当地的桌游店发现的。我没听说过，也没在网上看到过它的评论。我买下它是因为我觉得它的主题很好，结果发现它确实是一款非常有趣的游戏。所以，是的，它叫《古生物兽医》。有意思。
classic dinosaurs. And it's just a lot of fun. It seems like another good game where it's a good blend of strategy and luck and choice over which path path to take is this a fun game i guess i've never heard of it yeah i found it at my local board game store i had not heard of it i haven't really seen it reviewed anywhere online i picked it up because i thought it was a good thematically good and it turned out to be a really fun game yeah so. So yeah, it's called Paleo Vet. Interesting.
还有其他最后的推荐吗？就主题而言，我想我提到过《展翅翱翔》（Wingspan）是我和伴侣最喜欢的游戏。哦，是的。虽然我们最近没玩过。他们称它为一种“点数沙拉”游戏，因为里面有很多东西。它绝对不是那种两分钟就能解释清楚的游戏。需要几轮才能上手。
Any other last minute pitches? In terms of themes, I think I mentioned the word wingspan is my partner and I's favorite game. Oh, yes. Although we haven't played it recently. They call it a bit of a point salad game because there's a lot going on. It's definitely not one of those two minutes to explain. It takes a couple rounds to get under it.
但作为狂热的观鸟者，我们去旅行，回来后会说：“哦，对了，我们现在见过那只鸟了。”这很好。当我们去斯堪的纳维亚半岛时，我们确实看到了一些鸟，回来后我们说：“哦，即使我们不喜欢那张卡片，苍鹭之类的。”是的，对于双人游戏，《斋浦尔》（Jaipur）是个不错的选择。我想你曾经跟我提过这个游戏。是那个卡牌游戏吗？是的，没错。它的主题是中东市场。你在购买各种商品。它只是一款双人游戏，但确实是一款非常好的双人游戏。
But as avid birders we and we'll go away on a trip and we'll come back and then we'll be like oh yeah now we've seen that bird um you know nice which is uh what it was definitely when we were in scandinavia though we saw a couple birds and then we came back and we were like oh even though we don't like that card herons and and things like that yeah for a two-player game, Jaipur is a good one. I think you told me about this game at one point. Is it the card-based one? It is, yes. It's Middle Eastern Marketplace, is the theme of the game. And you are buying various goods. And it's only a two player game, but it is a very good two player game.
现在我得记住其中一个机制，基本上你因为第一个购买某些商品而获得更多分数。所以，你知道，我忘了那些商品是什么，但有香料、皮革之类的东西。但基本上，如果你是第一个购买某种商品的人，你会得到四分代币，而下一个人只能得到三分代币。所以有一种这样的机制。我不确定我记得是否完全正确，但就是这样。然后还有你可以选择的骆驼。
One of the mechanics now I've got to remember is you basically get more points for being the first to buy certain goods. So, you know, there's, I forget the goods, but there's like spices and leather and maybe some other things. But basically if you're the first to buy a good, you get the sort of four point token and then the next person to buy can only get the three point token. So there's a, there's a sort of mechanic like that. I'm not sure I'm getting exactly right, but it's like that. And then there are, and then there are camels you can choose.
每当我跟我儿子玩的时候，只要有骆驼，他就无法抗拒，因为基本上你可以选择垄断骆驼市场，拿走所有的骆驼，而不是去买其他东西。因为基本上你可以选择垄断骆驼市场，拿走所有的骆驼，而不是去买其他东西。骆驼可能会在几轮中积累起来，直到它变得非常有吸引力，因为当然，拥有最大的骆驼群可以得分。是的，他正在学习供需关系。是的。
And whenever I play with my son, he can't resist whenever there's camels on our face, like, because basically you can choose to like corner the market in camels and take all of the camels instead of buying something, you know, and the camels on offer. Because basically you can choose to corner the market in camels and take all of the camels instead of buying something. And the camels might build up over a few turns until it becomes very attractive because, of course, you get points for having the largest camel herd. Yeah, he's learning about supply and demand. Yeah.
所以那是一个有趣的游戏。有什么要避免的吗？你知道，一旦有了孩子，桌游就变成了另一回事。主要是因为你想避免，你知道，当你刚开始教孩子时，游戏非常简单。比如《糖果乐园》（Candyland），对吧？《糖果乐园》甚至不涉及骰子，我想。你是按颜色移动的，你翻开卡片，卡片上的颜色就是你移动到的下一个颜色空间，沿着那条蜿蜒的路径。那还可以，不是一个糟糕的游戏，你知道，至少在幼儿游戏方面。
So that's a fun one. Anything to avoid, you know, once you have kids, board games become a different sort of thing. And mostly because you want to avoid, you know, when you're starting out teaching your kids, the games are really simple. Like Candyland, right? Candyland doesn't even involve a dice i think uh it's you move by colors you move by yeah you turn over cards and the color on the card is that is the next color space you move to on the on the twisting right path that's okay it's not a bad game you know at least in terms of little kids games
但《蛇梯棋》（Snakes and Ladders），我们在英国称之为“蛇梯棋”，是有史以来最糟糕的游戏之一。它和《大富翁》（Monopoly）一样，是公认的最糟糕的游戏之一，原因有二：第一，我的意思是，那种沉重的道德说教背景并不好；但作为一种赛跑游戏，《蛇梯棋》需要精确的步数才能完成，你知道，你可以玩五分钟就快完成了，但20分钟后你可能还是快完成了，对吧？它就是那种游戏。这简直是折磨。最后，因为每次都是随机的，而且你必须通过精确的步数进入终点。在某种程度上，它比《大富翁》还糟糕。
but snakes and ladders or shoots and ladders uh we call it snakes and ladders in the uk is one of the worst games ever invented it's up there with monopoly as one of the worst games uh for two reasons one the i mean the heavily moralistic background is not good but but as a race game snakes and ladders requires a exact count to finish and you know you can play it for five minutes and be nearly finished and you can still be nearly finished 20 minutes later right it is that kind of game. It is just painful. And in the end, you're just, because it's random every time, and you must get in by exact count. In a way, it's worse than Monopoly.
至少在《大富翁》中，在某个时刻，你可以决定为了输而玩。你只会说：“好吧，我跟你交易，这样你就拥有了整套东西。”因为，你知道，我们已经玩了一个小时了，我只想让游戏结束。对吧。我甚至不知道那个道德上有问题的背景是什么。哦，我忘了，但基本上，你知道这个游戏，对吧？蛇梯棋。所以它的想法是，你知道，善良、敬畏上帝的孩子会前进，而那些在1800年代发明它时被认为道德上有问题的人则不会前进。我不知道。就是那种游戏。我没意识到还有任何……
At least with Monopoly, at a certain point, you can just decide to play to lose. You just be like, sure, I'll trade you so you have the whole set of these things. Because, you know, we've been playing for an hour, and I just want the game to end. Right. have the whole set of these things because you know we've been playing for an hour and i just want the game to end right should i ask what the moral i don't even know what the moral uh problematic background oh i forget but basically you know the game right snakes and ladders so the idea is that you know good god-fearing i, children advance and children who do things which are questionable in the eyes of whatever morality was around in 1800s when it was invented. I don't know. They do not advance. It's that sort of game. I didn't realize there was any...
是的。所以，如果你……我从来没玩过那些游戏，但你可能玩过，你听说过《Trouble》这个游戏吗？是的，那是另一个需要精确步数的游戏。是的，我想是的。我母亲非常喜欢那个游戏。是那个有“Pop-o-matic”装置的吗？没错，就是那个用弹出器的。我想它其实还有一个别名，可能是类似那样的名字。你弹出骰子，有四个人，你需要从起点出发，绕棋盘一圈，然后进入终点。我想你唯一能做的决定，或者说有两个决定。一个是如果你有多个棋子在外面，移动哪一个。移动哪一个棋子，是的。
Yeah. So, if you... I never really played those games uh but you probably have you heard of the game trouble yes yeah that's another exact count yeah yeah like I think so my mother absolutely loves that game is that the pop-o-matic one exactly yeah that's done with the popper yeah I think it's actually got an alternative name and it might be like something like that you know you pop something where you pop the dice and you've got four people you need to get from home to go around the board once and then in. And I think the only decision you can make, or there's two decisions. One is if you have multiple pieces out, which one to move. Which piece to play, yeah.
这不算什么。然后是另一个。这真的是唯一可以被称为策略的东西。但我想如果你掷出6，你可以，那是另一个选择。你可以带出一个棋子。你必须掷出6才能开始。是的，6，你可以带出一个棋子。
Which is not nothing. And then the other one. It's really the only thing that could be called strategy. But I think if you get a six, you can, that's the other option. You can bring someone out. You must get a six to start. Yeah. Six, six, you can bring someone out.
或者如果你已经有一个人在外面，你不能带出一个人然后移动6步。但无论如何，这几乎完全是运气，我会抓狂，心想……总之，我理解你的挫败感，因为那个游戏……我记得小时候，我总是会演戏，试图让它变得有趣，因为我觉得这个游戏无聊透顶，所以唯一能让它变得有趣的事情就是有人开始假装这非常重要，比如“现在我的人回到了起点”。而像《拼字游戏》这样的游戏实际上非常有趣。嗯，《大富翁》是个糟糕的游戏，对吧？因为它是我所说的
Or if you have a person out, you cannot take someone out and, and move six. But anyways, almost completely luck and i would go i would pull my hair out so much just being like and and uh anyway so yes i feel your frustration i because that game is just i would always when i remember being a kid i was i would like act out and try and like make it fun because i was like this game is boring as hell so like the only thing that's going to make this fun is like someone starts pretending like this is the most important thing being like now my person went back home uh whereas a game like scrabble is actually yeah very fun well monopoly monopoly is a bad game right um because it's it's what i've heard called
除其他事项外，它不仅美化了极端资本主义，还涉及财产和寻租。是的，这是一个“51%游戏”，对吧？这就是我听到的说法。一旦你稍微领先，就会有一个正反馈循环，对吧？所以一旦你理解了“51%游戏”背后的逻辑，当然，如果一个人占了51%，他们就会一路领先获胜。虽然《大富翁》有随机元素，所以这并不完全适用于《大富翁》，但基本情况确实如此。这其实挺迷人的。
among other things it's you know also besides the fact that it glorifies extreme capitalism um thinking property rent seeking yes it's a 51 percent game right which is how i've heard it called it's like like once you get slightly ahead it is there's a positive feedback loop right so once you get the idea of the's a positive feedback loop, right? So once you get the idea behind the 51% game, of course, if one person's 51%, then they run away with the win. Which, you know, Monopoly has random elements. So it's not totally true of Monopoly, but it's basically true. It's kind of fascinating, actually.
我想我在网上看到过。所以我显然有电子游戏背景，如你所知，很多电子游戏都在对抗那种“51%游戏”。有一种游戏，以我所知的第一款游戏为例，就是《超级方块战士》（Super Puzzle Fighter II Turbo）。总之，它是那种游戏之一，想象一下竞技版的《俄罗斯方块》，对吧？但不是《俄罗斯方块》。它是那种你不需要拼凑方块的游戏。你只是让不同颜色的方块堆叠在一起。当不同颜色的方块相遇时，它们会合并成更大的色块。
I think I saw online. So i obviously have a background in video games as you know a lot of video games fight against that kind of 51 game and there's a kind of game which is um exemplified by one of the first games i know uh is um super puzzle fighter to turbo extreme was it anyway it's one of these games where imagine competitive Tetris, right? But not Tetris. It's the one where you're not fitting the blocks in. You're just letting the blocks fall on top of each other in different colors. And when different color blocks meet, they merge into larger color blocks.
然后你可以引爆那些更大的色块，并把东西发送给你的对手去处理。好的，好的，所以它就像《噗哟噗哟》（Puyo Puyo）或类似的游戏，对吧？它是那种游戏之一，而且是面对面的双人游戏。它有一个非常有趣的特性：即将获胜看起来和即将失败是一样的。它不是一个“51%游戏”，它是一个持续反击的游戏。因为如果我给你发送了很多东西，是的，它填满了你的屏幕，这对你来说是个问题，但它也给了你一个巨大的机会，把一堆东西发回给我，对吧？所以它是双向的。有意思。所以它不涉及虚张声势之类的吗？或者它是街机游戏，对吧？所以你的东西是
And then you can explode those larger color blocks and send things over to your to your opponent to deal with okay okay so it's it's like po po or a game of that nature right it's one of these games and it's head-to-head two players um it has a very interesting property that being about to win looks the same as being about to lose it's it's a it's not a 51 game it's a it's a sort of continual comeback game because if i send you a lot of material yes it fills up your side of the screen so it's a problem for you to deal with but it gives you a huge opportunity to send a bunch of stuff back to me right so it works both ways interesting so it's like is it not a is that does that involve like bluffing kind of of or is that it's a it's an arcade game right so so you're things are
持续掉落的。有时你会得到引信，引爆不同颜色的方块，对吧？而且越大……所以你可能会得到一个2x2的红色方块，它们在这个游戏中融合成了更大的宝石，对吧？假设你得到一个2x3的，它会融合得更大，或者3x3的更大，对吧？宝石越大，它在几何级数上就越强大，对吧？所以你发送的东西更多。但每个角色——我正在想的这个游戏——都有一个类似《街头霸王》的角色选择。所以每个角色，你可以选择一个街头霸王作为你的战斗人员，他们发送给对手的颜色图案是不同的。
continually dropping sometimes you're getting fuses which set off different color blocks right and the larger so you might if a two by say you get a two by two of reds they fuse together into a larger gem in this game right and say you get a two by three it would fuse into an even larger gem or three by three even larger right and the larger the gem gets the sort of geometrically more powerful it gets right so you send over more stuff for large gems comparatively but every character uh this game this this game i'm thinking of had a had a sort of street fighter character selection so every character you can select the street fighter to be your combatant had a different pattern of colors they would send over to your opponent
当你引爆了一定数量的宝石时，你会发送给你的对手。当你引爆了一定数量的宝石，你会发送一打宝石。他们得到的图案取决于你选择的角色。有意思。那么发送东西的风险是什么？你快要发送东西了，但风险是他们能够利用这些东西做点什么？是的，完全正确。你刚刚发送了一堆宝石。
when you got you know a certain explosion of gems you would send over to your opponent when you got, you know, a certain explosion of gems. You would send over a dozen gems. The pattern they get sent depends on which character you picked. Interesting. So what's the risk at the end of sending, you know, you're close to sending something over, but the risk is that they'll be able to do something with that? Yeah, exactly. You've just sent a bunch of gems.
它们会落在你对手已经拥有的任何宝石上。它们可能会融合在一起变成更大的宝石。然后你的对手将能够引爆它们，并把一大堆东西发回给你。这就是为什么它不是那种一旦领先就一直领先的游戏。这是一种非常有趣的“持续反击”机制。是的。那真是……我正在尝试想其他游戏。我的意思是，《拼字游戏》与此并不完全不同。它绝对没有那种“哦，
They are going to fall on whatever gems your opponent already has. They're going to fuse together into larger gems, potentially. And then your opponent will be able to set those off and send a ton of stuff back to you. So this is why it's not one of these games where when you get ahead, you stay ahead. It is a very interesting mechanic of perpetual comeback. Yeah. That is... I'm trying to think of other i mean scrabble is not completely dissimilar to that it definitely doesn't have like uh oh
你快要赢了，但你可能快要输了”的感觉，但它确实影响了你在高水平《拼字游戏》中的策略。当你落后超过100分，或者落后一个“宾果”（Bingo）或更多时，你开始玩防御性游戏，而不是得分游戏。有防御性和进攻性之分。进攻性就是打开通道，所以任何高水平的《拼字游戏》玩家都在寻找我可以得分的“宾果”通道。如果只有一个通道，而你因为领先150分而试图进行防御，你就会一次一个地关闭那个通道，这样就没地方得分了。然后下一轮，玩家会尝试打开另一个对方无法关闭的通道。最好的玩法是“分叉”，即同时打开两个通道，这是无法阻挡的。因为如果你没有高分通道，你就没有
you're about to win you could be about to lose but there it affects the strategy that you play in high level scrabble when you're down by over a 100 over like a bingo or more you start to you start to play a denial game rather than a scoring game there's defensive versus offensive and offensive you open lanes so it's you'll any high level Scrabble player is always looking at where are the bingo lanes where I can score and if there's only one and you're trying to play defensively because you're up by 150, you're just always one at a time closing that lane so that there's nowhere to score. And then the next turn, the player will try to open another lane that that person can't close. And the best kind of play is where you fork, where you open two lanes at once, which is unblockable. Because if you don't have high scoring lanes, there's no
办法反击。所以有类似这样的事情。甚至某些国家以他们的训练方式而闻名。比如我刚看了一个视频，关于尼日利亚是如何成为《拼字游戏》超级大国的，因为他们有一个人在2016年赢得了世界冠军。他的名字叫惠灵顿。在尼日利亚，人们认为《拼字游戏》是一项运动，就像国际象棋一样，所以他们有训练资金。现在在全球排名前100的选手中，大约有40名尼日利亚的《拼字游戏》选手。
way for you to come back. So there's kind of things like that where and even certain countries are known for the way that they train. Like I just watched a video on how Nigeria has become a Scrabble superpower because they have this one guy that won the world championship in, I think, 2016. His name was wellington and it's uh designated in nigeria uh that scrabble is a sport the same way chess is and so they have funding for training and now like it's in the top 100 there's like 40 nigerian um like globally ranked scrabble players
前两名里也有两个。他们都以……或者其实我想他们说这只是个传说，传说他们打得很保守，但实际上顶级选手和其他选手一样具有攻击性。这很有趣。我知道你玩过竞技水平的《拼字游戏》。我参加过一次锦标赛。你对《拼字游戏》的了解比一般人深。我没怎么玩过，我只参加过一次锦标赛。你对《拼字游戏》的了解比一般人深。我没怎么玩过。我玩过《拼字游戏》。我知道它是怎么运作的。
and there's like two in the top 10 anyways and they are all known for uh or actually i think they said it's a myth but the myth is that they play very defensively but actually the top players they're they're just as aggressive as some of the other players this is interesting you know i know that you've played scrabble somewhat competitively uh i've i've played one tournament uh you have a deeper than average understanding scrabble like i haven't played much i've played one tournament. You have a deeper than average understanding of Scrabble. Like I haven't played much. I've played Scrabble. I know how Scrabble works.
但我没有在家庭娱乐之外玩过。玩得也不多。所以，你知道，我想像大多数人一样，我模糊地知道在竞技《拼字游戏》中，你需要知道所有的双字母单词，可能还有所有的三字母单词。四、五、六、七字母单词，至于你是否知道八和九字母单词是个问题。但还有另一套完整的策略，即实际控制游戏空间，对吧？这并不是显而易见的。你知道，大多数人，我想，会觉得知道所有的双字母和三字母单词在游戏结束时会是一个优势。但实际的玩法策略，比如你说的关闭通道或打开通道，以及随着时间的推移，
Like, but I haven't played it anything beyond, you know, with the family. And that not very much. And so, you know, I think like most people, I'm vaguely aware that in competitive Scrabble, like you need to know all the two letter words and probably all the three letter words. And four and five and six and seven whether you know the eights and nines is the question uh but then there's this whole other strategy of actually play space controlling the space of play yeah right which which is not something that is obvious. You know, most people, I think, would find it fairly obvious that knowing all the two and three letter words would be an advantage at the end of the game in particular. But the actual strategy of play of, like you say, closing lanes or opening lanes or various things and indeed the strategy over time of
管理你的字母库，意味着你不是在寻找……我假设你一直在寻找“宾果”，但你并不一定是在这一轮寻找它们。你可能是在尝试设置，尝试走最高概率的路径，以便在下一轮或之后的一轮设置一个“宾果”，或者希望，你知道，理想情况下每一轮都这样。但顶级玩法是在思考这些事情，对吧？是的，老实说，即使作为一个我称之为高于平均水平的严肃《拼字游戏》玩家，还有一个我不知道存在的世界级策略。直到我开始看这些威尔·安德森（Will Anderson）的视频，以及评论员对现在直播的《拼字游戏》锦标赛进行解说，这些在过去几年里是没有的。
managing your letter bank right to to mean that you're not looking for you're always looking for bingos i assume but you're you're not necessarily looking for them on this play you might be set trying to set up trying to you know try to go down the highest probability path to set up a bingo next turn or turn after or hopefully you know ideally every turn but um the top level play is look is thinking about things like that right yeah it's honestly even as a i would say above average like serious scrab player, there was a whole other world of strategy that I did not know existed. And still until I started watching these Will Anderson videos and, and commentators commenting on Scrabble tournaments that are now live streamed that weren't, you know,
人们所做的事情令人难以置信。所以，我不知道的一件大事是残局。每一位职业或精英《拼字游戏》玩家都会进行“牌位追踪”，所以你知道在游戏结束时，当袋子里没有牌时，你确切地知道你有什么，他们有什么。是的，根据棋盘……这是纯粹靠脑力吗？有规则吗？他们被允许写下来吗？是的，你可以写下任何你想写的东西。所以他们都有一个小本子，他们只是一个一个地划掉字母。你们双方都保留自己的分数，也有第三方记录。对吧。
in years past. And the things that people do are, it's incredible, like, so that one of the big things I didn't know about was endgame every every professional or uh elite scrabble player tile tracks so you know exactly at the end of the game when there's no more tiles in the bag you know exactly what you have and what they have yes and depending on the board is that something that is purely mental are there rules are they allowed to write down yeah that you can write down whatever you want so they all all players have like a little thing where they just scratch off the letters one by one. And you both keep your own scores as well as some third party. Right.
这只是《拼字游戏》的规则。所以你可以在游戏结束时进行推演。你知道你的对手有什么。你知道他们能拼出什么。所以对你来说，在简单层面上，显而易见的玩法是：“哦，我可以得这么多分。这是我最好的词。”但这可能会让他们以某种非凡的方式赢得比赛。所以你必须推演。
That's just kind of Scrabble rules. And so you can play out at the end of the game. You know what your opponent has. You know what they can spell. And so the obvious play for you at like a simple level is like, oh, I can score this many points. It's my best word. Could set them up to win the game in like some remarkable fashion. So you have to play out.
根据你时钟上剩下的时间，因为它像国际象棋一样是限时游戏，你会看到有人坐在那里七分钟，寻找通往胜利的唯一路径，这涉及三种不同的走法和布局。所以这就像国际象棋的残局。完全正确。是的。所以国际象棋，我相信对于棋盘上剩下七八个棋子的任何配置都已经解决了。计算机已经解决了它。类似那样。是的。
And depending on how many minutes you have left on your clock, because it's a timed game like chess as well, you'll see someone sit there for seven minutes finding the one path to like victory, which involves three different plays and like setting themselves up. So this is like, this is like end games in chess. Exactly. Yes. So chess, I believe, is solved for any configuration of seven or eight pieces left on the board. Computers have solved it. Something like that. Yeah.
但《拼字游戏》更适合人类找到这些路径，我想，因为它是……因为字典里的单词数量是有限的，特别是最后出现的双字母和三字母单词。所以，是的，我知道“Quackle”是一个可以完美解决残局的程序，尽管《拼字游戏》字典里有135,000个单词，取决于你使用的字典，有柯林斯版和北美版。总之，是的，它是可解的，但要做到这一点非常困难。世界上最好的选手可以做到，但有些东西确实非常难看出来。另一个非常非常酷的技巧，比如杰克逊·斯迈利（Jackson Smiley），是一位加拿大世界顶级选手，几年前曾上过吉米·坎摩尔（Jimmy Kimmel）的节目，参加那个带两个年轻《拼字游戏》选手的小孩竞赛。
But Scrabble is more amenable to humans finding these paths i guess because it's uh because there are a finite number of words in the dictionary in particular the two and three letter words that happen at the end so so yeah i know that um quackle is a program that can solve end games perfectly up to a certain amount as well even though there's i think 135 000 words in the scrabble dictionary depending on the dictionary you use there's a collins one and a north america one anyways right but yeah it is solvable but it is it's a lot harder to do like the best players in the world can do it but there there are some things that's incredibly hard to see and another really really cool trick like jackson smileyiley is a Canadian top world ranked player that actually was on Jimmy Kimmel years ago on that little kid contest where they bring on the two young Scrabble players.
他当时还是个孩子，上了那个节目。我想他和我年纪差不多。他现在还在玩，但他对自己的布局非常疯狂。他们知道：“哦，我手里还剩最后一个M，我可以把这个词钩住一个M。”所以我把它放在这里，它将是无法阻挡的，然后我会等待。所以看起来他只是在随便玩，你知道，其他精英选手会认出这一点并试图阻挡，但他们试图设置这些情况，他们基本上是在为自己设置一个无法阻挡的“空中接力”，因为他们手里有袋子里剩下的唯一一张牌。
He was, you know, when he was a kid, went on that program. I think he's roughly my age, plus or minus. And he still plays now but he is crazy for his setups that he will do where they they know oh i have the only m left and i can hook this word with an m at the end so i will put it here it'll be unblockable and then i'll wait and and so it looks like he's just kind of playing a whatever you know other elite players will recognize this and try to block but they try to set up these situations where they've they're they're putting something they're basically laying themselves up or like for an alley-oop that is unblockable because they have the only tile left in the bag
因为他们一直在追踪。偶尔你会看到像我以前见过的那样，有人玩了“EAU”，这是法语中的水，但在《拼字游戏》字典里。他们把它放在一个三倍字母格旁边。而“EAUX”也是一个词。他们的牌架上有X。所以他们是在为自己做准备。30分。不，X是8分，对吧？
because they've been tracking and every once in a while you'll see something like i've seen before where someone played eau which is a the french for water, but it's in the Scrabble dictionary. And they put that next to a triple letter. And E-A-U-X is also a word. And they had the X on their rack. So they were setting themselves up. 30 points. No, X is eight, right?
所以是X乘以3。但随后他们又玩了另一个以X结尾的词。所以他们拼出了以X结尾的词，加上像“TAX”这样的词。所以你最终为一个字母得到了48分。哇。因为它是两个词的三倍。是的。X在三倍格上。
So it's X times three. But then they played another word that ended in X. So they spelt O that ended in X plus something like tax. So you end up getting 48 points for that one letter. Wow. Because it's triple in both of the words. Yes. The X was on the triple.
好的。然后它看起来……我的意思是，精英选手会自动识别这些事情，比如：“哦，他们可能在设置一个Z的……双向三倍得分，你可以得到40或60分。”因为Z是10分。或者Z，我其实不知道哪个是美式的，我知道美式的是……是的，Z。总之，Z。但精英选手会立即看到这一点。但如果你只是随便玩，没人会注意到我在三倍格旁边放了一个A，而且我的牌架上可能有Z。但他们会立即看到。总之，这是一个非常简单的游戏，就好像……哦，这只是一个填字游戏。说到这里，我们一个小时后转换话题。
Okay. And then it can look like, I mean, elite players, they automatically always recognize these things where, oh, they might be setting zed a uh dual direction triple play where you get 40 or 60 for uh six times 10 for zed or z uh for i don't actually know which one's american i know the americans yeah uh anyways zed z american say z yeah z um but like elite players will see this immediately um but if you're if i'm just playing casually, like no one's going to notice that I dropped an A next to a triple and that I might have the Z on my rack. But they'll see this immediately. And, you know, anyways, it's a very simple game in terms of like, oh, you just it's a crossword game. Speaking of which, we'll transition now an hour later.
我们现在有两集桌游了。我们得把这一集分成两部分。嗯，我只是想在算法方面也插一句。好吧，我们会留着书和电影的话题，但我本来想说，阿夫拉（Avra）和我在约会时经常玩《纸牌游戏》（Cribbage），这是一款非常适合两人的游戏。还有另一个游戏我总是搞混，这是那个有29分和棋盘上插钉的游戏吗？《纸牌游戏》有……是的，没错。所以当……是的，没错。所以它有一个《纸牌游戏》棋盘，有插钉，你玩到121分，29分是最高分的手牌。好的，是的。所以你会发现一些《纸牌游戏》棋盘看起来像29的形状。没错。
We've got two board game episodes now. We're going to have to split this into two parts. Well, I just wanted to hook in also on the on the algorithmic side of things well we'll save the books movie but um i was gonna say um avra and i when we were dating used to play cribbage a bunch which is a great game for two players cribbage and there's another game that i get mixed up is this the one with the 29 and the pegs on the board or cribbage has yes that's right um so when yes that's right so it it there's a cribbage board has the pegs you play to 121 and 29 is the highest scoring hand okay yeah that's so and you find some cribbage boards that look like a 29 that's right
通常你会发现29形状的《纸牌游戏》计分在算法上非常有趣。这是我偶尔会回去重温的事情之一，作为一种编程练习。编写《纸牌游戏》手牌的计分程序，因为就像我说的，它在算法上很有趣。首先，计算《纸牌游戏》手牌有一个顺序。所以你首先要寻找……加起来等于15的牌，对吧？你的手牌是四张，还有一张额外的起始牌，你可以把它包括在计算中。有各种规则，所以首先你要寻找加起来等于15的牌。A总是1，从不等于11，所以A在《纸牌游戏》中总是小的。所以你在寻找15，寻找对子，寻找
that commonly you find the 29 shape cribbage scoring is very interesting algorithmically it's it's one of those things that i periodically go back to as sort of a coding practice the coding exercise is scoring a cribbage hand because it's like i say it's algorithmically interesting to begin with um there is a there is a an order in which you count up a cribbage hand so you're looking for to begin with uh cards that sum to 15 right and your hand is four cards your hand is four cards and there's an extra starter card which you get to include in counting um there are various rules so you to start with you're looking for cards that sum to 15 ace is always one never 11 so ace is always low in cribbage so you're looking for 15s you're looking for pairs you're looking
三张或更多的顺子。顺子，是的，我记得。然后你在寻找……有一个分数叫“Knobs”，或者我称之为“One for his nob”，因为这是我被教导的方式。如果你手里有一张杰克（Jack），且花色与翻开的起始牌相同，就得一分。我想你也可以因为同花而得分，尽管这比较少见。但让《纸牌游戏》计分变得有趣的是所有这些东西，还有它是一个组合问题。所以最高分的手牌是你手里有一张杰克和三张五，而翻开的牌是与你杰克花色相同的五。
for runs of three or more runs yeah i remember that and and what and what and then you're looking for there's a score called uh one uh it's called knobs or i say one for his knob because that's the way i was taught which is if if you're holding a jack which is the same suit as the starter card that got turned up it scores one point you can also i think score for a flush although that's rarer but what makes cribbage interesting to score is all of those things, but also the fact that it's combinatoric. So the highest scoring hand is you're holding a jack and three fives, and the turn-up card is a five of the same suit as your jack.
那手牌得29分。它得29分的方式是通过组合计算15。所以你有15、2、15、4、15、6、15、8。那是杰克与每一张五配对。对吧。那是8分。然后你有四张五。从四张中选出三张有多少种方法？
That hand scores 29. And the way it scores 29 is by counting 15s combinatorically. So you've got 15, 2, 15, 4, 15, 6, 15, 8. That's the jack paired with each of the fives. Right. There's eight points. Then you've got the four fives. How many ways are there to select three from four?
因为三张五等于15，对吧？这就像搭三角形，对吧？15、2、15、4。是的，完全正确。所以你有那么多分。然后你有所有五的组合对子。同样，你有四张五。选出一对五有多少种方法？
Because three fives are 15, right? It's like triangle building, right? 15, 2, 15, 4. Yeah, exactly. So you've got however many there are there. Then you've got all of the combinatorial pairs of fives. Again, you've got four fives. How many ways can you select a pair of fives?
你每选一对得两分。对，这就是我所说的组合。最后，那个“Knobs”的一分让分数达到29。那是额外的一分。是的，这在算法上很有趣。但它也会非常……不是单调，但我正在尝试想一种优雅的方法。可能没有数组单行代码，它会是一堆……优雅的方法可能是递归。是的，那是我通常做的方法。是的，直到我想到的那个例子。
You score two points for every one. Right, this is what I mean is combinatorial. And then finally, the one for knobs makes the score up to 29 that's the extra one point yeah that is yeah algorithmically interesting but also it would be very not monotonous but i'm trying to think of like the elegant way and it's like that's there's probably going to be no array single liner it's going to be a bunch of the elegant way to do it might be recursion yeah that's the way i normally do it yeah at first until it was the the example i was thinking of
比如7、8、6、7、8、9的手牌，这通常是我追求的。是的，那也是一手不错的手牌。这手牌非常好，特别是如果你有，比如，6、7、7、8，然后翻出一张9。一旦你有了双7，或者双8，组合就开始发挥作用了，因为你有7和8组成的15、2，另一张7和8组成的15、4，6和9组成的15、6。然后你有顺子，同样，你是在组合计算顺子。所以6、7、8、9是一个顺子，然后6、另一张7、8、9是另一个顺子，而且你还有一对7。
like the seven eight six seven eight nine hand which usually was what i was shooting for yeah that's also a decent hand that has the a very good hand this like especially if you have say um six seven seven eight and you get a nine turned up right as soon as you get a double seven in there or a double eight then the combinatorics start to come into play because you've got 15 two with seven and eight 15 four with the other seven and eight 15 six with the six and nine then you've 4 with the other 7 and 8, 15, 6 with the 6 and 9. Then you've got the runs, and again, you're counting the runs combinatorically. So 6, 7, 8, 9 is one run, and then 6 other 7, 8, 9 is the other run, and you've got the pair of 7s as well.
所以一旦你开始加倍，里面就有许多不同的计分，因为7作为15的一部分被加倍，同时也作为顺子的一部分被加倍。它在成倍增加。我其实在想，你能通过做排列来解决它吗？所以不，它不是排列，它是幂集排列。所以组合是顺序不重要，排列是顺序重要。幂集排列……组合是顺序不重要，排列是顺序重要。幂集是所有长度直到n。所以问题是，如果你取幂集，我想它是……而且它实际上可能需要是每个的排列。其实不，我不认为排列很重要，因为牌的顺序绝对不重要。
So you've got a lot of different scoring in there once you start doubling up, because the 7 is doubled as part of a 15 and also doubled as part of a run it's it's multiplying up i'm actually trying to think though is that could you solve it by doing a is it permutations so no it's it's not permutations it's power set permutation so combinations is order doesn't matter permutations order matters power set permutation so combinations is order doesn't matter permutations order matters power set is all the lengths up to uh n so the question is if you took the power set i think it's and it might actually need to be the permutations of each actually no i don't think permutations matters because the the order of the cards definitely doesn't matter.
你只是把它们保持在排序状态以检查顺子。如果你取你拥有的四张牌的幂集，对于四张牌来说，它不会爆炸得那么大。对吧。你能解决它吗？嗯，是五张。如果需要，可以包括第五张牌。这是其中一个增加复杂性的地方。例如，如果手里的牌花色相同，你可以有一个同花，
You just keep them in sorted order to check for runs. If you took the power set of the four cards you had, which for four is not going to explode that big. Right. Could you solve it? Well, it's five. The fifth card can be included if needed. That's one of the things that puts a wrinkle in it. Like, for example, you can have a flush if all the cards in your hand are the same suit,
那得四分。如果翻开的牌也是那种花色，你可以得五分，对吧？同样，翻开的牌是否被包括在顺子中，取决于你手里是否有三张顺子，这就足够了。但如果你能组成四张顺子，你也可以这样做。例如，哦，但如果也有四张顺子，你就不会因为三张顺子而得分。正确。好的，所以这打破了我的幂集模型，我试图想如果……如果你能从你的四张牌中创建长度为2、3和4的每一种组合，你能把分数唯一地映射到每一个组合上，然后把它们加起来吗？哦，那是对的。是的，顺子长度不适用于组合。顺子的内容会
and that scores four points. If the card that gets turned up is also that same suit, you can score five points, right? Likewise, the card that gets turned up may or may not be included in a run, depending on whether you have a run of three in your hand, that's sufficient. But if you can make a run of four you can do that too for example oh but you won't get points for a run of three if there's the run of four as well correct okay so that that breaks that breaks my power set model that i was trying to think if like if you could just create every combination of like length two three and four from your four can you map the points uniquely to each one of those and then just sum it up oh that's right yeah the run length does not apply combinatorically the contents of the run would
通过交换牌等等。是的，这是一个非常有趣的编程问题。而且它也很有趣，因为有算法上有趣的部分，还有一种代码设计部分，即你如何表示牌，如何表示手牌，如何表示牌堆和发牌，我认为这通常适用于纸牌游戏。哦，所以如果你是在实现整个游戏，
you swapping out cards and whatever yeah it's a it's a very interesting problem to code up um and it's interesting also just so there's now rhythmically interesting part and then there's a sort of code design part, which is how you represent the cards, how you represent the hands, how you represent the deck and dealing the hands, which applies in generally to card games, I think. Oh, so that's if you're implementing the whole game
你说的就是这个。是的，是的。黑桃Q是一个值还是一个引用类型？哦，是的，是的。托尼（Tony）的著名问题。链接到托尼的一次演讲。我喜欢数组编程中的方式，这是一个非常经典的技巧，你只需分配1到52，或者如果你想的话，0到51，取决于你的数组语言。我想0到51效果更好一点，因为
is what you're talking about there. Yeah, yeah. Is the queen of spades a value or a reference type? Oh, yeah, yeah. Tony's famous question. Link to one of Tony's talks uh i like the way in array programming it's a pretty classic trick you just assign 1 to 52 or 0 to 51 if you wanted uh depending on your array language i think 0 to 51 works a little bit nicer though because
你可以立即进行模13运算，所以你做模13来得到花色，对吧？因为你有……我相信你可以在其他语言中做到这一点，但在数组语言中真的很容易做到。你可以做这种索引选择，创建一个包含Unicode方块、红心、黑桃和梅花的字符串，然后你只需模13，你可以进行整数除法，然后索引进去。所以如果你有16，那将是，我不知道，比如红心7之类的。或者其实不，它会比那个小，红心3之类的。然后你把它整数除以13，你会得到1。然后你可以索引到你那四个Unicode符号的字符串中。
you can then do immediately mod uh 13 so you do mod 13 to get suits and right you because you have i'm sure you could do this in other languages but it's it's really easy to do in array languages you can do this uh index selection where you create a string of the unicode uh diamonds hearts spades and uh clubs and then you can just mod 13 you can go integer division and then index into. So like if you have 16, which will be, I don't know, like the seven of hearts or something. Or actually, no, it's going to be lower than that, the three of hearts or something. And then you integer divide that by 13, you'll get one. And then you can index into your length four string of those Unicode symbols.
所以，比如用几个字符，只使用0到51，我的意思是，这打破了托尼谈论的“使用值与引用”的整个原则。但这是一种让纸牌游戏运行起来，并在终端中显示看起来相当不错的牌的超级快的方法。是的，这很酷。
And so like in a few characters by using just 0 to 51, I mean, this breaks the whole using a value versus etc. that Tony talks about. But it's a super fast way to get like a card game going and to display things in a terminal that look quite nice. Yeah, it's cool.
所以，通过仅使用0到51这几个字符，我的意思是，这打破了托尼所说的关于使用值等等的整个概念。但这是一种让纸牌游戏运行起来，并在终端中显示出相当不错效果的超快方法。是的，这很酷。
I mean, you also need to deal with like court cards all counting 10 as far as the 15s. That's another you know, the value of the card is not the value of the card. For the pip cards it is, but for the picture cards, they're all 10, right? Yes. So when you're counting 15s, you need to take out that kind of thing. So there are enough sort of special case rules like that to make it interesting. It's not terribly complex, but it is more complex than simply power setting the cards, right?
我的意思是，你还需要处理像花牌（Court Cards）在计算15点时都算作10点的情况。这是另一个，你知道的，牌面值并不等于牌本身的点数。对于数字牌来说是相等的，但对于花牌，它们都算10点，对吧？是的。所以当你计算15点时，你需要排除掉这类情况。因此，有足够多这样的特殊规则让它变得有趣。它并不算太复杂，但比单纯地给牌设定数值要复杂一些，对吧？
Yeah. Maybe we should have a whole other episode on it. Because I remember one of the very first things that I did when I fell in love with programming, because I was studying actuarial stuff in school, I had to take two programming courses. And I was actually struggling in the very first one I took was a Python course, just intro to CS. And I was never the best student, I kind of skated through high school. And so you know, if things weren't immediately obvious to me, I was just like, this isn't for me. And finally, at some point, like halfway
是的。也许我们应该专门做一期节目来讨论这个。因为我记得我刚爱上编程时做的第一件事，因为我在学校学习精算，我必须修两门编程课。我其实在第一门课上很吃力，那是一门Python课，只是计算机科学导论。我从来都不是最好的学生，高中时我就是混过来的。所以你知道，如果事情不能立刻被我理解，我就会觉得这不适合我。最后，在某个时候，大概课程进行到一半时
through the course, there was this assignment. And I was like, this can't be that hard. And so I actually sat down, tried to figure out, you know, for loops of statements and stuff. And then I was like, wait a second, like, I did the assignment. And I was like, with these like, couple tools, you could do, you could do anything. And then like, the next two to three days, like disappeared. And I wrote this like 3000 line poker simulation. Cause at the time I was a big fan of, uh, poker, not gambling. Cause I couldn't gamble yet. I was too young.
课程进行到一半时，有一个作业。我想，这应该没那么难。于是我真的坐下来，试着去弄明白for循环、if语句之类的东西。然后我心想，等一下，我把作业做出来了。我当时觉得，有了这几个工具，你几乎可以做任何事。然后接下来的两三天就这么消失了。我写了一个大概3000行的扑克模拟程序。因为当时我是扑克的忠实粉丝，不是赌博，因为我当时还不能赌博，年纪太小了。
That's a whole different story. I don't gamble anymore. Probability. Yeah. Yeah. And, uh, hence you went into actuarial sense. Yeah. Statistics money.
那是另一回事了。我现在不赌博了。概率。是的。是的。因此你才去学了精算。是的。统计学，金钱。
I mean, there's, there's a whole books written about, you know, the overlap between Wall Street and poker and whatnot. Anyways, and that program that I wrote, though, was identifying the different hands. And all of it was nested for loops. I wish I could go find the code. It's on some hard drive somewhere. But it was horrific. But it worked for the most part and now i have like in small talk and bq in a couple languages these one-liners using like specific frequency uh methods or
我的意思是，有整本书都在写华尔街和扑克之间的重叠等等。总之，我写的那个程序是在识别不同的牌型。所有的逻辑都是嵌套的for循环。我真希望我能找到那段代码。它肯定在某个硬盘里的某个地方。但它写得太糟糕了。不过大部分情况下它能运行。现在我在Smalltalk和BQ等几种语言中，使用特定的频率方法或
collections that make it so much faster so much more beautiful it's it would be interesting to go back and refactor in the sense i think a lot of students too i remember helping uh someone that was doing a kind of poker assignment once and they were blown away when i was they were doing an elixir and i was like oh yeah elixir has all this stuff you know chunk by etc and they were like what the heck i was just gonna loop through this stuff and i was like yeah that's exactly how i would have thought when i was first learning it yeah i have a similar story one of the earliest things i wrote when i was a teenager in QBasic, QuickBasic, actually.
集合，让代码变得快得多，也漂亮得多。回去重构一下会很有趣。我想很多学生也是这样，我记得曾经帮助过一个做扑克作业的人，当我在Elixir中演示时，他们惊呆了。我说，哦，是的，Elixir有所有这些功能，比如chunk等，他们就说，天哪，我本来打算用循环来处理这些东西。我说，是的，这正是我刚开始学习时会想到的方法。是的，我也有类似的故事，我十几岁时在QBasic，QuickBasic里写的最早的东西之一。
Jason would say there's a difference between those. Was Yahtzee. I wrote a Yahtzee program that I spent a whole summer playing with my brother and sister. We would play together and, you know, it was the whole game. So it rolled the dice and then you could choose where to put the score and hold and all that, the play of Yahtzee. I see you have Yahtzee behind you there.
Jason会说这两者之间有区别。是Yahtzee（快艇骰子游戏）。我写了一个Yahtzee程序，花了一个夏天和我弟弟妹妹一起玩。我们会一起玩，你知道，这就是整个游戏。它会掷骰子，然后你可以选择把分数放在哪里，保留骰子等等，这就是Yahtzee的玩法。我看到你身后就有Yahtzee。
I love Yahtzee. Yahtzee is my favorite party game. It's another game where there is a hidden strategy, right, I think, that's beyond the surface meaning of the game, if you like. Because as a kid learning Yahtzee, I didn't fully understand that one of the strategies is like, you know, you roll the dice and you get a certain score, right? You get a certain outcome.
我喜欢Yahtzee。Yahtzee是我最喜欢的派对游戏。这也是一个有隐藏策略的游戏，对吧，我认为，如果你愿意的话，它超越了游戏表面的意义。因为作为一个学习Yahtzee的孩子，我并没有完全理解其中一个策略是，你知道，你掷骰子并得到一定的分数，对吧？你得到一个特定的结果。
And then you can choose where to score those dice right and you don't have to score them in places where they obviously score or places that you were going for right if they come out bad you could choose to take a zero in the ones exactly for example right because the most you can ever get in the ones is is five or five yeah uh with the bonus yahtzee admittedly but four let's say the most you're likely to get in the ones is four um so i had not appreciated that whole level of strategy when i first started playing yahtzee at the age of eight or whatever yeah yahtzee is a a game that is mostly luck i don't know if it's 90 10 luck and skill but i love i love yahtzee not typically it's like a new year's eve a party game where there's lots of people and uh i also
然后你可以选择把这些骰子放在哪里计分，你不需要把它们放在明显得分的地方，或者你原本打算去凑的地方。如果结果不好，你可以选择在“1”那一栏记零分，例如，对吧？因为“1”那一栏最多只能得5分，或者5分，是的，虽然有奖励Yahtzee，但假设最多可能得到4分。所以我刚开始在八岁左右玩Yahtzee时，并没有意识到那一层面的策略。是的，Yahtzee是一个大部分靠运气的游戏，我不知道是90%运气还是10%技巧，但我喜欢Yahtzee。通常它就像一个新年前夜的派对游戏，人很多，而且我也
too like i my strategy is like i throw full houses i don't care if it's my second i'm always going for yahtzee it's like i want the 500 game i think i scored 450 one time but that admittedly is like every opportunity i have to get a yahtzee i'm i'm gonna take it because even if there's a one in 216 whatever six of the power three is like i still have a shot and it's worth the 100 points bonus to me to like end up with 170 which is not a great score to like you know end up with a game once every 20 games that's like you know 400 plus stella which is like three or four yahtze once every 20 games that's like you know 400 plus stellar which is like three or four yahtzees uh because like that's it's it's worth it to suffer through 19 games to have this one glorious moment which is also the same way that i i race races is
也一样，我的策略是，我总是去凑满堂红（Full House），我不在乎是不是第二次掷骰子，我总是冲着Yahtzee去。我想得到500分的游戏，我想我有一次得了450分，但不可否认的是，只要有机会得到Yahtzee，我就会去尝试，因为即使概率是216分之一，也就是6的3次方，我仍然有机会，而且对我来说，为了最终得到170分（这不是一个好分数）而获得100分的奖励是值得的，就像每20局游戏中有一次能得到400分以上，也就是三到四个Yahtzee。因为为了那一个辉煌的时刻而忍受19局平庸的游戏是值得的，这和我跑步的方式一样，
i always go out too hard and it usually doesn't go well but then one day it's a great day um yeah one day when everything lines up you go out hard and you find you're able to continue and you run a negative split. See, I know some running terminology. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthePodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where
我总是起步太猛，通常结果不太好，但总有一天会是美好的一天。是的，总有一天当一切顺利时，你起步很快，发现自己能够坚持下去，并跑出了负分割（后半程比前半程快）。看，我也懂一些跑步术语。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthePodcast.com上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，
you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. Um... There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反大括号派。嗯……这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。